yeah welcome to this video yeah this is
just a short video to tell you what's
going on with the channel at the moment
and what will happen the next couple of
weeks yeah I have to apologize a little
bit because for about two weeks now
there's only been the Blitz videos on
the channel and nothing more I'd like to
do some more instructional focus content
but I was pretty much focused on
completing my first book which has been
a subject of discussion on the channel
for quite a while but i have to happily
state that my book is like on 99.9 % the
only thing that still left to do is for
me to just basically read through it
once or twice again to check that there
are not any kind of weird things still
left in there that that should be
corrected yeah for instance you at one
point you might have written well this
is similar as game this and that and
nowadays well the book has changed and
this game might not be in the book
anymore those kind of things so I have
to basically read the whole thing like a
couple of times make sure that this is
not happening and I can actually give
you a sneak preview and this is what I'm
doing here I'm opening in Word Microsoft
good and this is the book actually I can
scroll through it yes you seem quite
quite some pages we are close to 300
pages at the moment and it is basically
done I just have to check things and see
that everything still makes sense what I
wrote over the cause of time so I'm
Jerrica chapter intros and well that's
it I guess it will be will be nice um
it's just a couple of hours let's say
left for me to work on it yeah what else
is happening on the channel then yeah
with that out of the way I will do
coverage of Tata Steel the nice
tournament starting in the Netherlands
just today going to look at the Masters
Tournament even the challenges
tournament is quite quite good but the
Masters Tournament is of course an early
highlight of the
the chairs here we see that we have an
excellent field headed by world champion
magnus carlsen not sure if you can read
this probably let me use the zoom
function you ever got magnets playing
numbered number one and world champion
caruana as his main rival nowadays is
playing what number two and then we've
got aronian giri wesley so very nice
field and some very interesting
enterprising players as well so we got
um we've got the barrage abhava who's
really a very aggressive inventive
player very interesting player maxine
bashe lagrave also interesting we've got
woman world champion who you found
playing eventual playing very nice very
nice field I will do daily daily videos
on tata steel and if you are a member of
the icc the internet chess club on the
coming thursday which will be a next
week thursday i will also do the live
broadcast the official live broadcast
for the sse together with American
grandmasters your Benjamin I'll be on
the air for the whole for the whole time
doing live coverage this will only be
viewable for icc members of course um
yeah what else is there this is this
tournament is going if we look at the
schedule we've got a long tournament and
the final round is Sunday the 25th so
this will be the main focus on the
channel besides the usual blitz stuff
for the next two weeks i will look at
all the rounds doing a one game a little
bit more detail and the others a little
bit yeah like an overview we will see
it's a very very very nice event what do
we have today actually i didn't even
check Giri cards and ok it's round one
kara wanna playing begins ding Liren
also very strong Chinese player so great
event yeah when this is over we will
have january twenty fifth and i have to
say that the week after that i will be
are we doing probably not so much in
terms of other things than the blitz
star
because I've been playing a tournament
myself starting on februari the first
this will be a closed round robin Grand
Master tournament in my you're calm I'm
trying shooting from webmaster norm but
I mean it will be difficult I couldn't
really train any any much anything
anything substantial so just hoping for
a good event and also for a little bit
of yeah relaxation on this nice Island
I'm looking forward to that beginning of
every i will definitely cover my games
from this tournament on the channel not
sure if i'll be doing it during the
tournament while i'm actually playing it
or right afterwards you will always have
the daily Blitz videos for entertainment
and the autumn gem of information which
i'm not quite sure that in the first
week of februari i'll have the time
during the tournament to do any coverage
of it not sure and also not so clear how
the things like internet connection
works out in the hotel and so on f to
check that maybe i'll do something even
on everyday needs to be needs to be seen
so I'm pretty busy up to this point like
februari m eighth or ninth and after
that the the normal things resume and
i'll be doing instructional videos often
on the channel and this brings me to
another thing that i want to want to add
to the channel and want to introduce and
i would like to add a regular type of
video and this is a video where i'll be
analyzing on games of yours so games
that viewers sent to me for review and i
will do a video on those games trying to
highlight interesting points about the
games possible mistakes that have been
made improvements or them whatever
happened yeah so please send me your
games yeah there is no particular
limmud on kind of there are no
restrictions to what you can send me
just make sure that you get the mail
address right you want to write to my
mail address that will also be in the
video so send it to to my mail address
which is actually my first and last name
and then at gmail com so easy to easy to
do there is no cost involved or anything
you can just send me send me your games
preferably one game maybe not not a ton
of them just maybe one game per person
and then I will decide what what games i
can i can use for that make sure that
you write to me if you want to have your
name published or not this would be
helpful yeah because well if you don't
want to I what I definitely need is the
ratings of of you and your opponent so
that I have some kind of a DM what I'm
talking about it wouldn't make much
sense of you send me a game and your
1,500 player you can probably play an
excellent game for your rating level and
I still would find some mistakes
assembly you have to view again
according to the rating standards of the
player say I cannot expect perfect play
from a player is like 1500 of a
different thing that can be expected if
if the players like 2500 I mean then you
probably won't send me your game you
know but I guess you you can figure out
what I'm what I'm talking about yeah I
hope you enjoyed this little overview
and hope you're looking forward towards
those new exciting things send me your
games and I will actually it will take
about a month until such a video will be
released so don't worry if you send it
to me it's not forgotten it's simply
that there are other things happening
before that but I will definitely come
to this um to this to this um come back
to this this idea starting in February
probably februari 10-11 wrong
time okay thanks for watching hope you
enjoy the talasea coverage starting
today thanks